premiers pas sur le terrain en tant que
préfet des yvelines pour jean jacques
brot après un parcours riche qui lui a
permis notamment de travailler en
outre-mer ou encore au japon
retour dans un département qu'il connaît
bien j'ai la chance d'y être étudiant à
hec ya quelques années dit passer mon
permis de conduire à verser j'habitais à
jouy en josas quand vous l'avez compris
au vésinet aussi l'intérieur membre
je connais un peu le département je
connais plusieurs personnalités
éminentes de ce département très heureux
d'y être en poste même si jean jacques
brot ne sait pas encore combien de temps
durera son exercice à la tête de la
préfecture des yvelines
il connaît d'ores et déjà les enjeux de
notre département
il ya des dossiers de sociétés
extrêmement important des dossiers
d'urbanisme des dossiers religieux sont
les questions graves qui méritent un
grand investissement est d'abord de ma
part beaucoup d'humilité de modestie
jean jacques brot succède à serge morvan
une fonction qu'il aura exercé pendant
deux ans et huit mois et qui aura marqué
sa mémoire
malheureusement il ya eu l'attentât de
magnanville j'ai passé la nuit dans
cette rue
non je ne vais pas m'étendre là mais et
je veux pas revenir là-dessus mais
c'était très difficile
l'ancien préfet ait dû quitter ses
fonctions vendredi dernier non sans un
petit pincement au coeur
mon principal regret c'est de partir je
serais bien rester encore longtemps dans
les yvelines comme préfet des yvelines
il ya encore tellement de choses à faire
nommé commissaire général à l'égalité
des territoires serge morvan aura en
charge la préfiguration de la future
agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires